o dia todo sam exame é realmente um
desafio falar da criatividade dá uma
média falar sobre meta criatividade como
consegui falar com criatividade em 15
minutos e criatividade
temos todos uma ideia do que é o menos
os acadêmicos porque temos que realizar
a tal criatividade disse só com o centro
tem inspiração e 99% de transpiração mas
não sabemos muito bem o que a
criatividade eu vou tentar
apesar de não sabermos se há alguma
maneira de dizer o que a criatividade
com algumas ressalvas salvas porque
sendo 15 minutos ia vendo outras pessoas
a falar de criatividade e eu vamos
restringir a que eu chamo de atividade
cognitiva por parte da própria em 12 no
diário oficial porque poderia estar a
falar da criatividade humana com a ajuda
da inteligência artificial isso prometem
mais é mais comum em pessoas que já
terem sido expostas essa criatividade e
usarem na sua investigação
inclusivamente portanto também não é só
a criatividade oficial do design no
marketing no segmento das artes porque
vão dizer ouvir outro ou outros
jogadores aqui nem sobre a criatividade
burocrata e que infelizmente às vezes
impera a criatividade científica
todos esses tópicos poderiam manter se
ão todos tanto tentou que visa a
criatividade mental algorithm mental
porque não é com corporal não vou falar
do diâmetro rose avançar e com criativos
podem ser adversários danças indianas
usou outra do outra província qualquer e
algorítmica por e veremos o que quer
dizer porque tem te ver com os
computadores com dever ser escutado em
computadores
portanto perguntas e respostas para
circunstanciar circundar um pouco é o
âmbito desse toque de criatividade a
resposta é sim iremos ver exemplos a
frente
existem métodos para cometem
criatividade eo talento e criatividade
pode ver a criatividade do domínio é a
criatividade no outro mas um dado ser
humano pode ter meta criativo sabe ser
criativo em vários domínios ou os vários
humanos e em conjunto até ter uma
criatividade distribuída e pois a
questão se a metro nos espera criar
métodos criativos
por exemplo eu estar a fazer estoques
dilma me empenhar na meta criatividade
tanto que eu tinha que ser meta criativa
acerca da problemática da criatividade e
com o mar e como encontrar os tópicos
apropriados
num dado a condado foco mas não sabemos
bem existem métodos para meta criativa
tipicamente quanto lutamos alguém como é
que você criou o iso e inventou o
próprio método para fazer e criatividade
das pessoas não sabem explicar muito bem
ea pouca investigação justamente sobre o
assunto
por isso ia pergunta a perguntar se após
a meta a criatividade ser programada
porque se nós conseguirmos usar o poder
do programa do computador para perfazer
crise para fazer métodos criativos quer
autônomos que o computador ou se quer
métodos criativos
em interação em simbiose com humanos
seria excelente ter uma alavanca de beta
criatividade como gerar métodos
criativos os médios criativos certamente
não tão fixo para todo o sempre haver
ainda muito por descobrir sobre métodos
criativos e em todas as áreas o céu vai
nos ajudar a perceber como é que pode
haver métodos criativos que filha só
eram possíveis do computador
portanto se e meta criatividade não for
uma energia não for uma posse provado
então seria positivo instituição que eu
tenho procure se não tivesse criativas
mas totalmente e de de serviço
algumas perguntas respostas é que a
criatividade credibilidade sobre como
fazer esta coisa especificou que o
aquela o jogador bridge criatividade
mais plena e tal
se é existir é criatividade geral será
uma fronteira do eva do outro homem e
máquina
quer dizer o homem que irá estragar a
festa nesta fase em que já aceitam que
seja mais máquinas tenham os primo
emoções
teremos naquela altura dizer não é a
credibilidade somos só nós não só nós é
que fazemos smac estão fora
isto é e do nosso produto antropomórfico
as perguntas se os extraterrestres não
podem ter criatividade e um que ter um
corpo igual ao nosso cérebro igual a
nossa banca poder e ser criativo teriam
que ter as nossas emoções que ser
criativo
isso faz parte de uma problemática
genérica da questão o que é o que é
virar uma máquina o que pode ser
definido com máquina
que filme não sabe dar uma resposta
digamos que toda a gente aceita
pior a própria concessão de maquiné vai
evoluindo tanto que era máquina aviões
tchecos quer uma coisa como com
engrenagens não é uma máquina
hoje engrenagem é uma engrenagem
abstrata nós aliás em informática
falamos de falamos de batidas obstante
ainda por cima as máquinas podem
aprender e evoluir muito ficam os
portanto a questão de dizer que na
quinta foi feita por um homem com tanto
que ela faz não é mais do que o que nós
temos que fazer fica prejudicado por fax
bells evoluírem e aprenderam sozinhos
como hoje em dia de greve se tornou
freqüente mas também cria questão de se
as limitações da máquina não só a final
apenas um espelho das nossas limitações
que têm células não conseguem e somos
nós que escolhemos então somos nós que
não conseguimos
somos nós não sabemos bem o que a
criatividade como não sabemos
especificar consultas e detalhe nem se
não sou nem conseguimos ensinar é nosso
na faculdade
queremos o que a criatividade como temos
exemplos e os meus mestrandos de boa
aqui um caminho você xinga o amigo que
não está orgulhoso do time
os doutorandos de aqui um mapa e não sei
bem os caminhos mas você nem por batata
que hão de encontrar qualquer coisa
os pós doc tem que descobrir um mapa
qualquer tem que inventar um mapa e não
sou capaz de dizer como o o homem que
inventou este banco espera para criar
conhecimento avançado puro examinar a
criatividade em ciência porque
sobrevivemos alguma coisa e eu estou uma
das três de essa crise de dívida em que
se pretende resolver um problema
é não não propriamente é conseguir um
produto uma móvel com o mercado ou seja
uma realidade que não vi nos disse que
as coisas são verdadeiras ou não
não é uma questão de convencer uma
sociedade sem prejuízo para essas formas
de criatividade e portanto esta
criatividade civic e um gol antes do ice
saber que o problema sexual é que são
relevantes e quando alguém que eu vou
investigar agora é uma questão de fé é
uma questão despeza da pesada do que a
que eu tirei meu será verdadeiro é e
essa é a de ver quais são os contornos
que eu volte a diferentes pessoas têm de
o fazer mas também se ele perguntar
quais a influência do sono da e precisa
opção é preciso não largar o problema é
que a febre storm de tudo isso são esses
componentes da idéia da criatividade e
quais seriam no computador nos
equivalente
criamos o equivalente destas componentes
também a credibilidade novamente
pessoalmente surpresa mas muitas vezes é
conhecida a solução deixou de ser
surpresa que era surpresa há 30 anos
agora já não é surpresa o ego o mc 2 foi
uma grande surpresa e hoje em dia todos
as entende é 7 ea conhecimento comum
portanto será obrigatório haver surpresa
é me parece muito simples a alguma
solução para um problema é mesmo muito
complexos pode ser uma solução também
era o que eu estava à espera aliás eu já
tinha tido uma pesada que este lema ia
ser verdade que eu até fui tentar provar
é questão que pode agora simpa comecei a
pensar por um lado na final e admitindo
por hipóteses que nós éramos capazes de
criar e ao grito os criativos e entender
por algoritmos conjunto de regras x
temáticas a que podem inclusive mental
tô automotivo ficar se poderá ver
algoritmos criativos e eu vou dar
exemplos alguns que existem agora poderá
ver algo itos meta criativos ou seja se
tiver um conjunto de algoritmos criativo
será que eu posso
mateus todos dentro de um algoritmo meia
hora
o algoritmo meia hora que permitem então
a meta criatividade entra entre os
vários gritos criativos e até nos dias
criatividade
aí eu posso responder com segurança que
sim ou seja desde que haja o grito dos
criativos nós sabemos informática que o
emocionava arquitetura e universal
emitem qualquer ao grito criança é isso
o computador o computador eis uma
espécie de eletrodomésticos em um
respirador
temos vários do computador temos um e
temos sempre os programas do mesmo
computador e por isso é universal
a atividade envolve vai invenção do
problema descrição do espaço onde eu vou
procurar soluções e você vê o que é uma
sucursal propriedades é que deve ter a
função como é que eu sei que encontrar
uma solução jurídica métodos que o digam
onde é cada um de forma a pena começar a
procurar onde é que é plausível que
estejam as soluções e preferir entre
soluções candidatas
portanto é é a criatividade a jal é uma
coisa complicada que exige a trade off e
equilíbrios entre os recursos
disponíveis o tempo disponível a
qualidade das funções aprender com erros
acreditar não é simplesmente uma
experiência a a alguns preencher eca é é
um processo que exige referimento e e
correções que uma série de exemplos de
programas criativos que pôr ordem em
termos de tempo de várias com várias
cada um deles com várias especificidades
o primeiro deles é o programa de das
gazelas que é um jogo simples 51 já
tinha feito basta explorar todos os
ganhos possíveis
o game of life ball muitos de vós vamos
ou fazer evoluir vida artificial num
plano recuado e em que se mostra que é
possível reproduzir a vida é assim a
vida artificial podem ter o primeiro na
teoria universal
o foco maior prova desse dos matemáticos
e tem a ver com a conceber o mostrador
do grêmio de um teria eu trabalhei
vários anos e fiz um monstro tiremos de
um teria e lembro bem e 4 está
documentado ser esse meu artigo sobre
uns 60 páginas
eu mostro como é que eu tive que
programar a criatividade do computador
perceber simetrias dentro do diagrama
geométricos criar pontes auxiliares para
ajudar a fazer a demonstração e essa
criação de pontos auxiliares
é rechaçado o computador é ter essa
capacidade de invenção e mostrou-se
essencial para fazer essa demonstração
tiremos o foco do problema é é
demonstrar que bastam quatro cores para
preencher um plano para o mapa o mapa de
países móvel que os dois países não
tenham a mesma cor e foi necessário
realmente metros do do computador porque
a cerca de 1400 casos seminário de tudo
isto podia se ver de conectividade no
plano entre regiões e isso era
impossível para um ser humano fazer essa
busca é exaustivamente desses caras e só
conseguiu ser provável tivemos dessa
galera
o musical tem a ver com ser capaz de de
ouvir de seila peças nos a descobrir
qual é esse qual é sintaxe colega
gramática
depois disso pode sintetizar peças que o
comum dos mortais serão original do
próprio computador
os outros casos você pensa em melhor por
cento
lubango o torneio internacional de
xadrez do ó também ganhou os humanos
no último ano jogou nem explicar todos
estes casos e particular o diploma em
detalhes falou agora que os apontadores
é bom e vou ter que conversar então para
o peru fim de terminar
enfatizar este aspecto
um dos medos exemplos mais patentes
criatividade da própria evolução de vida
que não se exibirem nós já anteriormente
tinha foto então a gente saiba quem
acredita em theo dante design será que
houve um deus que criou um algoritmo que
o próprio tudo viu evolução com a
criatividade que a evolução tem os
gritos não só para resolver um problema
específico encontrar uma solução bom
problemas se fixam para gerar
possibilidades combinatórias
possibilidades como nós vemos na vida e
movimento teoria matemática dos jogos
vivo funcionários em que eu tenho
trabalhado nos últimos nos últimos sete
oito anos
então o livro saiu também no último ano
para além do livro o nosso diretor
freeway está em português
este é um livro sobre justamente a
programação aberta em máquinas que têm a
ver com a capacidade de gerar regras
girar regras de forma é que uma
população de computadores possa conviver
entrasse na área todos beneficiem o
problema do grêmio mesmo porque a
evolução da areia desde então todos a
competir uns com os outros eo problema
não resolve porque temos todos a
comprarem tem sido resolvido
basicamente é muito precisa e
ultimamente é usado para saber compor os
sujeitos autônomos que são cada vez mais
autônomos a cooperar entre si
a última oficina duas semanas em são
paulo brasil era sobre como dar culpa as
máquinas mostrando digamos
matematicamente que vale a pena ver um
pouco culpa
espero que todos convivam e todos se
beneficiem de ver um pouco de culpa
conclusões sobre a criatividade é que
devemos levar pra cá e contar contar
algumas histórias dentro
witty faymann até esta fase de estudo
na verdade só coisa só compreendendo uma
coisa quando eu sou capaz de criar e o
computador é o instrumento ideal para
criar este tipo de coisas para criar a
criatividade afinal de contas estar
sabendo jornal o que a criatividade do
fato dia criarmos já sabemos gerar
alguma criatividade
já sabemos gerar alguma criatividade
não sabemos ainda como fazer é meta a
criatividade seria o grande projecto de
investigação que eu disse que esse ato
não ajudava porque observa do instituto
para fazer isso e não no nome era propor
instituto não tomar e altamente
interdisciplinar e por isso há essa é a
essa dificuldade a esses recursos
não sei quem é que iria dar dinheiro que
o mercado queria saber a minha
criatividade mas mais cedo ou mais tarde
iria certamente
portanto estamos
o registo é o meu eu amo meu tempo suave
estamos num novo paradigma e expele
guiné é ver comum e as máquinas estão
cada vez mais o maranhão até porque são
construídos por humanos claro as
limitações das máquinas são antes mas
dadas as nossas vidas somos nós não
conseguimos fazer as máquinas e limpeza
porque vai haver cada vez mais simbiose
entre o homem máquina não é uma questão
de ter o organismo ao longo dia de luta
quem é que vai ganhar os homens máquinas
certamente que haverá lutas do mês com
máquinas contra outros homens com
máquinas existe é o nosso é o estado da
nossa espécie e portanto o homem magri
viviam em conjunto e amy o meu
a previsão é que no futuro a alma já
começa a ver uma vivenda plantar é que é
um elemento distribuída de serviço como
no chute na que nos robôs humanos criará
a autoestima do oeste ea credibilidade é
cada vez mais uma criatividade
distribuída
ninguém parece que eu estava a falar da
criatividade só ocorre no cérebro uma
pessoa mas não tem que ser entendida
como algo que é promovido uma forma
distribuída e pronto agora é
simplesmente me é um pouco cedo de de
publicidade descarada e transmitir é que
terminei